talk I'll be talking
our journey to implement visual Sir John
Allegro all the only work done here was
done together with eros or Boyer and
cuttlebug unfortunately they couldn't
join us today so let's begin with the
basics what actually is visual search
let's imagine that we have such
situation that friends a friend asked us
hey could you buy me this dress on
Allegro I don't have a neck under but
she sent us only a picture I would say
ok sign up for yourself
it's easy takes a minute but in the end
I'm trying to find it for an hour
we could try simply to type down red
dress and see what results we get but
unfortunately those are just descent not
all the dresses are exactly what we've
been looking for we can narrow down the
search by using some attribute filtering
we can type in that the color is red we
have long sleeves there was no visible
pattern and we can get pretty decent
results we have the dress and the first
row the third one looking pretty similar
but what about this one which color
should we fix it is it blue or white we
know that the sleeves are long but I
have no idea what pattern is this to me
it looks like a Chinese post line but
there is no such filter to pick so it
would be hard but since we have a
picture we can obviously use it we can
represent a picture as a tensor of three
RGB channels this is a simplified
diagram for one channel and we could use
this to find the most similar images in
our database so for this dress we get
five most similar images that look like
this and I would say that the ID all
have just one thing in common that is
they're all lying on really ugly floor
and there is nothing nothing more so
since just the pixels are not enough we
can use neural networks and see if that
helps we'll be using a model called
ResNet which was originally designed for
a classification task but we are not
going to use it for classification will
be simply taking the representation from
the penultimate layer the
before classifier and using that to
obtain closest images obviously the
right approach for this would be
transfer learning training sub network
as resonate from scratch would be quite
time-consuming so we'll use the version
trained on image net as we all know the
image net data set we have there 8,000
classes starting from dogs and cats
ending with airplanes and trucks so
model trained to classify those may not
be the perfect scenario to find a
similar dress but let's use those
representations and see what happens the
results are well we'd no longer get the
ugly floor but the results are not
really much better but honestly it's
hard to say if anything has changed so
let's settle for some metric how we can
measure the effectiveness of such such
search here we'll be using accuracy at
five as a percentage of successful
queries whereby successful query I mean
one when we're within five five most
senior images we find the item that
we've been looking for and failed one
when we don't what are the results when
it comes to numbers the pixels didn't
work well image net was 200 times better
and we get two percent accuracy which is
not great so maybe let's try something
different
we could try to predict the attributes
instead of predicting instead of
predicting dogs and cats and so on we
could train our network to predict what
attributes and that dress has we have
quite a lot of data we have 700,000
offers just in the dresses category and
each offer is described with several
attributes
let's see if our model can learn nerves
and how does that affect our training
but first we have to know if our model
actually can learn those attributes here
again we have to pick some metric for us
it will be area under the ROC curve and
as you can see from the graphs of the
training progress we quite quickly go to
97% so this is a really good result I
would say that suspiciously good result
and why is that turns out that there are
many duplicates in our data set and
what's worse those duplicates are not
exactly the same there is a slight
translation between one and the other
image for example is shift by one pixel
which ends up that we cannot duplicate
the distinguishes easily and we end up
with a data leakage between the training
and testing data sets so how can we get
rid of those obviously by using some
more sophisticated application our
pipeline took several steps first we
would auto crop all photos to get rid of
Tarentum translations then we'll compute
a perceptual hash on discrete cosine
transform and we will add some
information about hue as P hashes are
color invariant and using those hashes
we'll be able to detect dublicate in our
data set here you can see histogram of
our duplicates in our original data set
and as you can see on some instances we
had over 600 images were pretty much the
same so if we get rid of those our data
set suddenly became become much smaller
around 20% of what we had in beginning
the results still are quit really good
we get accuracy of 33% so I would be
quite happy with that but how does it
translate to actual images and actual
image search I would say that the
results are not as good as I would have
hoped we can see that we can get address
of overall the same cut the same
neckline length of sleeves we can even
find the Chinese processing dress the
second one but still it's not really not
really there it's not visually similar
also we have lots of categories with no
attributes so we wouldn't be able to
scale this approach up to for example
notebooks or our phones also we're not
controlling what we are learning or
basically telling our network ok could
you predict those attributes and then
we're using the representation
to find similar images this is not
always possible so maybe we can try and
find to find some other approach that is
more direct the answer may be Sammy's
Network which basically is constructed
as follows instead of using single image
and classifying something we provide two
images for the training then we pass
them through our encoder we get a
embedding for both images and then we
are trying to predict if those are the
same the same dress it would be our
positive or two different dresses it
would be negative and we will be losing
using contrastive laws for this but this
is not not important now so we will not
get into the details but there is a hard
question how can we get such pairs for
the negatives it would be quite easy as
we just can pick two random images from
our platform and we get a negative pair
but when it comes to positives it's much
harder we could turn to external data
sets for example Stanford online
products we have over 120,000 image per
scroll from eBay unfortunately there are
no fashion images and we were supposed
to start with that category also there
are some better data sets for example
deep fashion where we have exactly what
we were looking for we have nearly 1
million image pairs of coving then we've
got some other smaller data sets like
darn or fashion AI unfortunately they
all have just one thing in common they
are for non-commercial purposes so we
cannot use them okay so if we cannot
turn to something external maybe we have
the data already on Allegro for example
we have such cool feature as product
reviews our users like them they write
them quite often and what's better they
post photos of the products they've got
so this would be the perfect scenario
because we get one nice shop shop
looking photo and then another one taken
in
natural environment by the user probably
on themselves or lying somewhere this
should be perfect but unfortunately
while on the entire Allegra we have 41
thousand such pairs for dresses we have
just 27 and as you all know 27 is not
enough to train a neural network so what
do we have a lot on our leg row we have
lots of offers so we've got offers with
multiple images so we could simply pick
two images randomly from an offer and
provide them as a positive pair then we
can train the model on those this way we
have one and a half million pairs just
for dresses so the numbers are there but
did it work no we get six percent
accuracy and this is not a really good
result so what can we do now in machine
learning we can either go for better
data or better model I firmly believe
that better data is crucial so I will
start with that and let's take a look at
the photos that we actually have in our
data set we have some one will call them
useless pairs where for example we have
a dress and a size table this may be
very useful for the customer but for our
model it's pretty much impossible to
learn from this so that's not useful for
us also we have a bigger problem we have
a travel naive image pairs we have
pretty much the same image on multiple
photos are added by the seller therefore
our model learns a very very shallow
relationship between those images and
eventually the generates the similarity
between pixels and that didn't work at
all we could classify images that we
have in our data set and simply divide
them into few categories for example we
have product images either on its own or
on a model in a shop fashion or we have
the same the same items on the street in
more natural environment so we can
create those
of useful images and then we have also
some less useful images we have collages
of multiple photos which are widely
popular in fashion category but
unfortunately those are not really
useful for us as we cannot pick just one
color and then compare it with something
that's single on an image then we've got
close-ups on details like this button
and while this may be again this may
again look nice it's hard to see our
model learning how the dress looks based
on a single button then we've got all
the size tables directions to shops some
logos and the etc that end up in the
trash category and everything has it we
were unable to classify classify in the
other category so we could split our
dataset into those categories and
basically clean it before the proper
training but to do so we need this
classifier and we need to train a
classifier we need some images that are
already classified and it's hard to see
anything else other than simply
annotating them by hand which is really
time-consuming and very tedious so
fortunately we can be able to clever
here we can use something referred often
to as active learning so basically we'll
take few hundreds of photos will
annotate those this will take I don't
know
an hour or so then we'll train our model
based on that we will take all the
remaining pictures will get predictions
for those and then we'll take those
pictures where our model is certain
which category to assign and put them to
the labeled ones then take some of the
unlabeled and then some of the images
where our model had no idea which
category to assign reallocate them and
retrain our model do this few times and
within a dozen or so hours we get a data
set of 20,000 images and accuracy of 98%
so this is quite good let's use that to
clean our data set and see if that
helped we'll take all our images image /
we'll start with the pictures in the
offer then we'll use the classifier to
predict their type I will get one of
those eight categories then we'll
discard those giant categories and from
the useful types will create pairs but
we would like to create them so they
differ on the product product model and
Street shop dimensions this way our
model hopefully will learn about the
product itself and not around about the
background about the setting it which is
it's displayed unfortunately this does
reduce our data set quite significantly
we started with when I have million
random pairs now we have only 12,000
filter pairs so that's even
significantly small small but it works
we get 21 percent accuracy which is way
better than what we had with random bars
okay but that's still worse than 33
percent so we have the better data now
let's go to the better model we can use
something called triplet laws where
instead of providing pairs for training
will provide triplets we have an unco or
a positive and a negative Unger is often
referred to as query then have a
positive that's similar to our query and
we have to provide some negative with
item that's different with an image
that's different from what we are
looking for so the idea is that we would
like to move the embedding of the
positive and the anchor as close as
possible to themselves and then we want
to push the negative further so then
when we are looking for an image the
meaning of the positive image is closer
this sort of makes sense
so let's formalize it we would have a
loss function that takes a triplet of
anchor positive and negative we would
like to minimize the distance between
the anchor and the positive then we
would like to maximize the distance
between anchor and negative but just by
some margin we don't want to push it as
far as possible we don't really need
that
so if it's further than its some margin
then it's okay so that's at that term if
our if if we actually have a positive
that's closer to an anchor than our
negative then we don't want to learn
anything here
so our lose function will be zero and it
works finally we get 50% accuracy so
it's better than the attributes but
maybe we can do something else
TripIt loss is still an ongoing area of
research so there are multiple ways to
improve it we could use we could start
with the selection of our negatives we
assumed that if the negative is far
enough then we don't want to push it
further away so this is generally right
it makes sense
but the problem is that our current
negatives as the model is training as
the mall is training are already far
enough so we get really easy negatives
and our model is learning nothing new as
this triplet satisfies our scenario so
we what we want are hard negatives where
you find something that's closer to the
query then the positive plus margin such
approach can be often called hard
negatives mining or if you are looking
for the heart negative within your
training but it would be the bad heart
strategy here we have a graph showing
percentage of active triplets over the
course of the training so what I mean by
an active triplet is say one that we can
learn something from so basically our
loss loss value for that triplet is not
zero so as you can see for random
negatives we quickly get a drop to 10%
so that means that only 10% of our data
actually allow us to learn something new
for heart negatives we started hundred
percent and then we end up at around 50
which is a much better result so then
how does it translate to our results we
get much better results 71 percent
accuracy just by applying her negatives
instead of random negatives so this is
quite quite good but this is just a
number let's see if it really worked in
the upper row we have the model based on
attributes as shown previously and the
lower row we have hard negatives as you
can see we deal with the color much
better but we have some problems with
coherence when it comes to attributes
our dresses in the lower row do not all
have the same length of sleeve in the
same neckline although they do look
pretty similar at least to me so what
can we do okay just one more example it
really worked for the address with
Chinese posting pattern because we were
able to find three exact matches but
when it comes to the fruit and the fifth
dress still again we have the same
problem we have different lengths of
sleeve or no sleeves at this in this
case so the obvious idea would be to
take this model which is way better when
it comes to color and combine this with
attribute prediction as I said
previously we cannot always use a drift
prediction but when it comes to fashion
it's pretty straightforward we can't
settle for it and we can use it so we
would create a model that would combine
those two we'll take our triplet we'll
pass all the images from our encoder
it's still the same ResNet as previously
then we will get embeddings for each
image we'll compute our triplet loss on
those images and then we'll add a
classification head in some
classification for multiple attributes
now comes the question which one is more
important what's more important getting
the dress of the same color or looking
for dresses with the same neckline
length of sleeve and so on I'm not
guessing I have no idea we'll refer to a
technique introduced by Alex Kendall for
multitask learning which basically adds
a sigma parameter for each lost term and
then the model learns
those parameters along with the weights
during the over the course of the
training
therefore we don't have to wait amber
ourselves but the model will adjust
those weights as the training progresses
does it work no we get slightly worse
model and this is really surprising
because for me it made sense so let's
take a look again what might have
happened so basically you had this this
architecture and what I didn't tell you
was that we had also a l2 normalization
layer for embeddings this works
brilliantly for triplet loss because we
put those embeddings in the same space
it's easier to find them but for
attribute prediction it does not
necessarily ROS works especially with
soft marks so what we did was to reroute
the input for our attribute prediction
and provide them with enormous
embeddings now it works
we've got 74 percent accuracy it's
better than just harder negatives maybe
the result is not really shocking is
just in just three percent but it's
still better so what else can we do
how else can we improve this model as I
said previously we are still using the
same resonate model as backbone and it
still pre-trained on imagenet so let's
take a look at two into pre-training and
maybe we can do something about this we
have a very good quality data set for
fine tuning where we have high quality
Triplets we have hard but something but
we don't have a huge data set to pre
train our model so recent paper from
Facebook proved that free training on
huge data set even if it's not perfect
works
they used Instagram and they produce
they were predicting hashtags so we can
grow the same idea and try it on our
data set basically the problem here is
that obviously they did
make the model public but for
non-commercial purposes so we cannot use
it but another go we have lots of offers
so we can go back to our random person
election so we'll take the first image
from from an offer it would be our query
or an anchor then we'll take another
image as a positive maybe the second
image just without know something then
we'll apply our heart but but heart
strategy and find the hardest match in
our training data set this way we get a
data set with over 100 million offers
there 400 million images and we called
it random heart triplets which made
sense at a time as if you recall collect
correctly on image net pre-trained we
had just two percent then we using
random purse from from dresses we got
six percent now pre-training for a few
days on whole electron huge data set
gave us 37 percent so this is quite
right it gets close to the attribute
prediction model but this is just for
whole other group this is just a base
for us to start from so let's combine it
with our model where we combine
attributes attribute prediction and
triplet loss and in the end we have pre
trained
tween one model which gets 81% for me
that's great result but would stay cloak
well all dresses have the same pretty
much cut they have the same length of
sleeve they are all almost red and to me
they look really good but what will
happen if you actually didn't have a
picture you have just some vague
representation of what you would like by
in your head if you can draw maybe you
can draw this and maybe it works we did
try that on this new bonus show and
turns out there is one that's quite
similar but ok no one has to know how to
draw it maybe worse so maybe some
doodling will be enough
this is not something that we're trying
to achieve but thankfully it turned out
that our model generalizes quite well
and simply drawing something is enough
to find it on Allegro thank you for your
attention
[Music]
if you have any questions I will be
happy to take them I would like just say
that we are also hiring we are looking
for research engineers and data
scientists so if you think that you can
beat our 81%
please join us we'll be more than happy
to welcome you question great orchid in
great case by the way what was the
because I think I'd miss it so
misunderstood what was the at the output
of your model and was it embedding and
if it was embedding how you managed to
search effectively with the vector we
are using a it's called Feist it's an
engine from Facebook to find basically
the most similar factors the neighboring
vectors so it's but you just how many
samples you had for search let's say
because you have to compare them so I
don't know what's the base for search
but you mean on the evaluation or well
offer production production for
production we have all the offers so we
have we will have when it's all
production ready for the whole Allegra
it will be hundred million offers to
search in cool so it works another
question yeah hi thank you for your talk
and I have one question we will make
this model available for community to
play at least as a search as a product
it will be available we will be running
first external tests in the first months
of upcoming here but when it comes to
simply giving out the model I'm not sure
yet
what may be thank you one more
hi thank you for a speech have you tried
have you tested semi-hurt triples
instead of hard ones yeah we did try
that it didn't give us any gain we also
tried few different approaches to find
negatives we did try to find them in our
whole data set but it also didn't work
really well we are still working on it
so probably during our some next
presentation will tell more about it
Thanks all right thank you so much
greater plows put a talk okay